bonjour katia les protestataires restent
donc mobilisés ce matin ah oui plus que
jamais là je suis au rassemblement du
blocage donc de cet incinérateur d'issy
les moulineaux 17 heures ce matin les
agents se sont regroupés ils avaient
éteint deux fours ici vous le savez les
fours de trois ans siné rateur de la
région parisienne ont été bloqués depuis
hier ivry saint-ouen et issy les
moulineaux d'ailleurs à ivry pour
l'anecdote c'est le maire en personne a
le maire communiste qui a lui-même et un
les machines alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les ordures ne
vont plus être incinéré il s'agit de
6000 tonnes de déchets par jour qui
concerne les déchets de 6 millions de
parisiens et d'habitants de la petite
couronne les déchets vont s'entasser
dans des fosses que va-t-il heures à
venir
on va en discuter mais je rappelle que
ici les agents sont en grève depuis le 5
décembre ils sont impactés par cette
réforme des retraites qu'il conteste
et aujourd'hui il passe à la vitesse
supérieure pour protester et je suis
maintenant avec marc bontemps qui est
secrétaire général des producteurs
d'énergie parisien et il va nous parler
de cette de cette grève alors dites-nous
et que va-t-il se passer avec les
ordures mais en fait aujourd'hui on est
on est sur un blocage des installations
pour une raison assez simple on a un
gouvernement qui n'entend rien et malgré
50 jours de grève extrêmement forte des
salariés
rien n'a bougé la copie n'a jamais été
revu faut savoir que sur toutes ces
discussions qu'on a eues avec le
gouvernement aucune proposition de la
cgt n'a été entendu et qu'aujourd'hui
l'intégralité des salariés non pas
seulement ceux de notre secteur vont
être impactés ce qui est inadmissible
sur cette réforme c'est que notamment
tous les salariés qui ont la peine
habitée non dans leur métier comprennent
les salariés qui travaillent dans le
bâtiment dans des métiers difficiles
il n'y a aucune prise en compte de ce
gouvernement alors qu'on aurait pu
imaginer que qu'on aime mesure réelle de
l'espérance de vie entachée par nos
métiers les difficultés qu'on a deux
dents etc en fonction de ses difficultés
de cet entassement d'existence les
salariés puissent bénéficier de ces
pénibilité et puissent anticiper leur
départ oui vous pouvez nous parler
justement de cette pénibilité c'est les
ovaires les matières ici qui sont assis
ici dans nos métiers à nous on a
effectivement les horaires décalés et
des matières des matières différentes
donc beaucoup de produits chimiques qui
sont intégrés dans les centrales et des
salariés qui voient des expositions
importantes avec une espérance de vie
qui est diminué du fait de ses
expositions
mais je le redis encore une fois
l'importance pour nous c'est pas
uniquement sur ces corporations
on est bien sûr l'ouverture à la
pénibilité à l'ensemble des métiers et
c'est bien ce qui fâche également dans
cette réforme c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
seul focus qui est fait par le
gouvernement c'est de montrer du doigt
les métiers qui ont déjà c'est
pénibilité ou une prise en compte de
difficultés dans leur travail
alors qu'en fait il faudrait généraliser
cela il faudrait que les salariés
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont mourir plus tôt
puissent partir plus tôt on a une
réforme aujourd'hui qui va contraindre
les salariés à travailler plus longtemps
à y partir avec une pension plus basse
c'est inacceptable dans un système comme
la france dans un pays industrialisé
on ne peut pas accepter aujourd'hui
qu'on travaille plus longtemps pour
partir avec moins de pension on arrive
sur un système identique aux états unis
où demain nos nos anciens partiront à 60
à 65 ans en retraite et devront
retourner travailler à 70 ans 81 ans
pour pouvoir manger et survivre
c'est inacceptable mais c'est pas propre
uniquement à nos métiers
vraiment le message qu'on veut porter
dans toutes nous on est sur l'énergie
ont fait partie des salariés des yeux
gdf gaz de france qui ont déjà été plus
baptisé en grande partie il ya une
augmentation sur la facture des français
qui est de plus en plus forte qui va
encore grandir parce qu'aujourd'hui le
principe c'est bien de tout mettre dans
les mains de la finance et d'ailleurs je
rappelle que cette réforme elle est pas
fait pour le peuple mais elle est bien
faite aujourd'hui uniquement pour donner
ça au système financier
que ça soit les banques ou système
assurantiel merci beaucoup marc
longtemps en tout cas ici la nuit
suivant la mobilisation des agents de la
sonatt heures 10 heures
moulineaux pardon avec une mobilisation
très forte de la cgt et l'arrêt des
fours et là le blocage actuellement avec
des petites barrières pour faire un
barrage filtrant pour que les fours ne
redémarre pas